翻訳: 椿原 脩平
校正: Makoto Shigei
（映像始め）
（映像終わり）
今　皆さんに観ていただいた映像は
札幌パルクールクルー
SPKという北海道大学にある
パルクールのサークルの紹介映像です
SPKは今から三年前
私が大学2年生に ちょうどなろうとしていた時
札幌で一緒にパルクールをやっていた
秋野隆太という男と作った団体です
当時　北海道大学にはパルクールをやっていてる人間は
私しかいなかったため
毎週のように北大に通い
俺は北大法学部二年の秋野だと
新入生に向かって大ボラを吹きながらビラを配り
体験会を開き
数ヶ月間一年生にバレずにやり続けるという
すごいことをした男です
そんな秋野の無茶のおかげや
他のメンバーの協力もあり
今ではSPKは大所帯
20人を超える大規模のサークルになりました
札幌市が主宰するスポーツイベントで
小学生500人以上にパルクールを
体験していただいたり
あるいは大学祭でパフォーマンスショーを
三年連続で実施するなどしています
ちなみに 秋野は翌年北大に無事現役で合格し
自分が立ち上げたサークルに
新一年生として入部するという
なかなか不思議な体験をしている男です
さて 私はパルクールをやっている人間
トレーサーです
[トレーサー
パルクールを実践する人々の総称　フランス語]
トレーサーとして
長年パルクールを教え 伝え続けてきた身として
今日皆さんには
是非皆パルクールを好きになっていただきたい
ファンになっていただきたいと思っています
いや　それじゃあもったいないですよね
トレーサーになっていただきたい
そう思っています
跳び箱がありますね
僕は頼んでいないのですが
誰が準備したんでしょうか
皆さんお分かりですよね
跳び箱があるということは そうです
今日は会場の皆さんにパルクールを体験していただこう
そう思っています
皆さん心の準備はよろしいでしょうか
こちらからだと見えないのですが
もちろんスニーカーで全員参加されているんですよね
大丈夫でしょうか
はい　誰がいいですかね
皆さん目をそらされていますね
はい冗談です
すいません
今日はですね　残念ながら
皆さんにパルクールを
この上でやっていただくということはありません
でも　皆さんには是非我々がどうやって
パルクールをやっているのか
というのを知っていただきたい
だから 先ほどの映像にあったような
私たちの動きに行き着くまでに
どうやって僕たちトレーサーがレベルを上げているのか
どうやってあのような怖いシュチュエーションの中で
自分をコントロールしているのか
それをお伝えしたいと思います
ちなみに 先ほどの映像を見て
皆さんどういった感想を持たれたでしょうか
猿みたいだ　よく言われます
忍者 スタントマン 怖い　なるほど
でも一番の感想はおそらく皆さんが疑問に思っているのは
結局パルクールってなんだろう
飛んだり跳ねたりするのはわかったけど
何をすればパルクールなのか
子供の遊びとどのように違うのか
そこが一番の関心の的だと思います
ですので 最初はまず
パルクールとはいったい何かということについて
簡単に説明させていただきたいと思います
［パルクールとは 走る・跳ぶ・登るといった移動に
重点を置く動作を通じて 心身を鍛えるスポーツです］
これは 日本パルクール協会のウェブサイトで説明している
パルクールのミッションです
パルクールとは端的に言えば
走る動作 跳ぶ動作 そして壁を登る動作
といったような人間が本来できる
移動する動作に重点を置いて
心身と精神ともに強くしていこう
そうやって鍛えていこう そういう考え方
トレーニングにおける　概念を指します
ですから パルクールは捉え方によっては
スポーツにもなりますしアートにもなりますし
パフォーマンスにもなりますし
ただの移動術としても使えます
さっぱりわからないですよね
ですよね　ありがとうございます
実は　パルクールは何かということに対する
世界的な統一見解というのは未だにありません
なぜなら パルクールにはルールもなければ
競技化もされていないからです
ですから　我々一人一人が
パルクールとは何かということを自分で考えて
納得した上で日々練習に励んでいます
ですから 自分がやっていることは何かという考え方は
人によって全然違いますし
場合によっては
お前がやっているのはパルクールじゃない
ふざけるなみたいな喧嘩が起こることが 今でもあります
おそらく 走る、跳ぶ、登る という三つの動作については
９割のトレーサーに共通することだと思いますが
なぜそれをやっているのか それが何を意味するのかについては
全く人によって異なります
私は７年間札幌でパルクールをやり続けてきました
高校生の時に始めて
ずーっとなぜ自分はこのパルクールをやっているのだろう
このパルクールの何にとり憑かれたのだろう
パルクールとは一体なんだろうということを
考え続けてきた結果
今では一つの結論に至りました
パルクールとは
自分を知り、弱さと向き合い、挑戦し続けること
私はこのパルクールの本質とも言えるような考え方を
いつも動きの練習をするときだけではなく
自分の日々の生活レベルにまで落とし込んで
パルクールをライフスタイルとして実践している人間です
今日 会場にお越しの皆さんには
このパルクールのライフスタイルからいかに
いかに自分と向き合い挑戦し続けるのか
人はどうしたら自分と向き合えるのか
そう言ったところをお伝え出ればと思います
突然ですが 今から皆さんに
簡単なテストをしていただきたいと思います
皆さん右手をあげてください
よろしいでしょうか
手のひらを自分の方に向けて
小指に意識を集中させてください
大丈夫ですか
自分の小指をじっくり眺めて
他の指を一切動かさず
小指だけを曲げてください
わかりますか
薬指を動かさずに小指だけを曲げてください
すごい光景ですね
はい 左右の方と自分の小指を比べてみてください
おそらく 薬指も一緒に曲がってしまうという方が
たくさんいるのではないでしょうか
完全にこう言う形だけで
小指だけを曲げることができた方
挙手していただいてもよろしいでしょうか
１０人くらいでしょうか
ありがとうございます
ご協力ありがとうございます
この小指と薬指が独立して曲げられるかどうかという話は
あの　もうやって頂かなくても大丈夫です
小指が独立するかどうかというのはですね
いろいろ諸説があるんですが
一般に一定の期間トレーニングしたら誰でも
ほとんどの方はできるようになると言われています
ちなみに私のケースでは
羽田空港から新千歳空港の90分のフライトの間
ずーっと飛行機の席に座りながら
自分の指だけ見つめて
曲がれ曲がれ曲がれ曲がれ ってやり続けた結果
新千歳空港にちょうど着くあたりで
ピッてできるようになったということを覚えています
皆さん是非飛行機の中でやってみてください
さて そろそろ皆さんお気づきだと思うのですが
小指が曲がるか曲がらないかというのは
パルクールにおいて登る壁の高さや
あるいは壁の登る速さとは全く関係がありません
もちろん
私が小指の話でお伝えしたかったのは
我々の体にはこの小指の例のように
気づいていないだけで まだ知らないだけで
ちょっと正しくトレーニングするだけで
いくらでも開花する
そんなが能力に満ち溢れているということです
ここで小指から全身に話を広げていきましょう
これは 札幌市内のとある公園で撮影した
私のパルクールの写真です
左足で飛んで 数メートル先にある
１メートル程度の高さの岩を飛び越え
その先に着地するという動作をやっています
このジャンプは私が人生でやった
全てのパルクールの動きの中で
最も頑張った 大きかったベストショット
ベスト・オブ・パルクールマスターだと思うのですけども
この飛距離 写真の上から測定してみると
多分５メートルもないと思うのですけど
多分４メートル半とか その辺りです
ちなみに皆さんご存知かもしれないですけど
日本の女子中学生選手の陸上選手
走り幅跳びの全国記録は６メートル19センチです
つまり 私が全力で22歳の時に飛んだこれは
女子中学生よりもはるかに負けています
悔しいですね
でも ここで一つの新しい疑問が生じます
では５メートルや６メートル いや７メートルを
跳ぶような走り幅跳びの陸上選手を
みんな この公園南区にあるんですけど
連れてきたらこの岩を跳び越えられるのでしょうか
つまり 人類の本来のベストパフォーマンスというのは
目の前に見慣れない障害物が置かれたシチュエーションでも
遺憾なく発揮することができるのでしょうか
これがまさにパルクールの醍醐味です
ほとんどの方は跳べなくなってしまいます
何故なら目の前にものを置かれたということが
自分の知らないシュチュエーションだから
自分の中でいきなり 跳べないかもしれないという
恐怖心が芽生えてしまうからです
ここで そもそも人間にどんな能力があるのか
我々人間に備わっている身体能力について
考えてみましょう
僕たち人間には 走る能力、跳ぶ能力、壁を登る能力
ここまではさっきお話ししました
それ以外は 狭い足場でバランスを取る能力
それから スケート選手のようにくるくると回転する能力
そして 低いところをくぐったり
あるいは細い隙間をすり抜ける能力
そして四つん這いで歩いたり
地面を這ったりする能力
こういったものは皆さん生まれた時から
一定レベルで備わっています
この中からその場でジャンプし
小さな段差に飛び乗るという動きに
フォーカスして話を発展させていきます
せっかくなので　この跳び箱を使いましょう
今からこの一段の跳び箱に跳び乗るという動作をやります
今から両足で跳んで着地するという動きをやります
よーく僕を見ていてください
皆さんよろしいでしょうか
いきますよ　せーのっ
ふー
（拍手）
ありがとうございます
今日一番のジャンプでしたね
ちなみに 今の一段の段差に跳び乗るという動作
皆さんに これをやってみてくださいと言ってもおそらく
え わたし嫌ですとは
そんなにならないんじゃないかなあと思います
なぜでしょうか
それは皆さんが日常的にやっている動作
つまり 階段やエスカレーターを登る動作と
この跳び箱の高さがほとんど変わらないから
この跳び箱に飛び乗っても怪我をしないということを
皆さんの身体が無意識に
本能的に理解しているからです
では この跳び箱が跳び箱ではなく
全く同じ高さの一本の鉄パイプがあったら
どうなるでしょうか
我々人間は 跳び箱に跳び乗るのは怖くなくても
鉄パイプに跳び乗るといわれた瞬間に
ものすごい恐怖心を覚えるようになります
で 考えてみてください
さっき跳び箱に跳び乗った時に使った
ジャンプ力 筋力
鉄パイプに飛び乗るのに使うのに使う身体能力
基本的にほとんど差はありません
違うのは 跳び箱に着地する場所と
鉄パイプの幅がものすごく違って
鉄パイプの方が細くて乗れるのかが
わからないという点だけです
つまり 我々人間が鉄パイプに跳び乗ることに対して
恐怖心を感じてしまうその理由
それは鉄パイプが細すぎて
ちゃんと着地できるかわからないから
足を滑らせえて こけて
怪我をしてしまうかもしれないから
もうちょっと正確にいうと
狙ったところに 数センチのズレもなく
ちゃんと着地できるかわからないから
その一点につきます
となれば やることは可能ですね
これがパルクールの考え方です
狙ったところに100パーセント
数センチのズレもなく着地できるようになればいいのです
この跳び箱を使って練習しましょう
鉄パイプを使うのはちょっと危険すぎます
この跳び箱の真ん中
ここに丁度鉄パイプが埋まっている
そんなイメージを持ってください
今から鉄パイプの上に跳び乗る練習
１回目 テイクワンをします
いきますよ
これが本物の鉄パイプだったら僕の脛はえぐれています
これは 別に跳び箱でもレンガでも
コンクリートブロックでもなんでも構いません
こうやって自分ができない動き
鉄パイプに跳び乗るような動きを
擬似的に他のものに置き換えて
500回でも 1000回でも
できるようになるまで練習します
1000回この跳び箱が
鉄パイプだとイメージして跳び乗った
そのあと 全く同じ高さの鉄パイプの前に立った時
私たちに見える鉄パイプの光景は
初めてそれに飛び乗ろうとした物とは
全く別のものになっています
皆さんが駅の階段やエスカレーターを
一段二段 ジャンプで登れる
あの感覚と全く同じ感覚で
トレーサーは
鉄パイプの上に跳び乗れるようになっています
私はパルクールを始めた時
２メートルも３メートルも離れている柵の鉄パイプに
全力で走って飛ぶ そんな馬鹿げたことを
自分がやる日はこないと思っていました
何故ならそういった能力は
本当にもともと運動神経が高くて
かつ自分の実力にすごい自信があって
その上なんでもできる
そんなスーパーマン達にしかできないと思っていました
でも パルクールを始めてからもう７年経ちます
毎回の練習で自分のできないこと 怖いこと
そういったものの障害物の前に立って
大丈夫だ頑張れ
絶対俺ならできる　絶対できる　いけ！
そうやって自分を鼓舞しながら
少しずつ少しずつ
できないことに挑戦し続けてきました
毎回の練習 すごく小さなことでもいいんです
すごい小さなことでも一つずつ 自分のできないこと
新しいことに挑戦し続けていくと
ある日突然
いや この動きは一生できないだろうなあ って
思っている動きに自分が挑戦している日がきます
鉄パイプから鉄パイプに飛び移る
そんな普通人間がやらないような動きであっても
この会場にいらっしゃる皆さん全員が
２年間本気で練習すれば
100パーセントできます
断言します
パルクールというのは
確かに跳んだり跳ねたり登ったりするスポーツです
日頃からはランニングもしていなければ
いつもエレベーターを使って通勤している
そういった方がいきなり始めるのは
少し難しいかもしれません
でも パルクールにおける本質的な考え方というのは
他のスポーツであっても 学業であっても
あるいは　趣味であっても人生であっても仕事であっても
変わらないと私は思っています
すなわち 自分の今の実力をちゃんと見つめて
何ができて何ができていないのかを理解する
心の中での恐怖心や弱さと向かい合う
そして それを知った上で 常に新しいことに挑戦し続けて
500回 1000回と反復練習をしていく
そういったライフスタイルを続けていけば
必ず皆さんは 数年後 全く別の人間になっています
世界を目指す研究者でも
社会を変える起業家でも
オリンピックを目指すスポーツ選手でも
あるいは ただただ世界を好きに旅するバックパッカーでも
何を目指してもいいと思います
でも 常に自分の中にある心の弱さ 恐怖心
昔から嫌だと思っていたこと
あの人いなくなんねえな
この仕事やりたくないんだよな
そういった少しでも自分の中にある
弱さ 恐怖心に常に立ち向かっていってください
自分の中にある弱さや恐怖心を乗り越えると
その克服が新しい自信を呼んで
また新しい弱さに挑戦できるようになり
それがどんどんどんどん自信を積み重ねていきます
今日私が皆さんにお伝えしたいことは一つしかありません
自分と向き合って 挑戦し続けてください
ありがとうございました
（拍手）